يجب أن يؤدي الاستخدام غير الضروري وغير
المتناسب للقوة إلى إنهاء
الأساليب القديمة وعقلية الحصن
لأولئك الذين يمارسون السلطة
ببساطة لا تعمل
في الواقع ، مما يؤدي إلى تفاقم الوضع الوحيد الذي
نحن فيه الآن في أزمة حقوق الإنسان الكاملة
النساء والفتيات  يجب أن تكون قادرة على الشعور
بالحرية والأمان في الأماكن العامة دون خوف
من العنف أو المضايقة للعيش في
أمان وتكون قادرة على المشاركة في
الحياة العامة على قدم المساواة مع الرجال.
السجن
وفقًا لمصادر موثوقة ، بلغ
تقدير متحفظ لعدد القتلى
حتى الآن أكثر من 300 من بينهم
ما لا يقل عن 40 طفلاً ، وهذا أمر غير مقبول ،
وقد تم حتى الآن اعتقال 14000 شخص بمن فيهم الأطفال في
سياق هذه الاحتجاجات ، وهذا رقم مذهل.